Jack had to die it's that simple if I
had to make the raft a little bit
smaller I'll make it smaller could jack
have fit on that door at the end oh my
gosh like I said I have no clue I'm so
down for that conversation it's
ridiculous isn't it look we could have
all fitted off yeah I think he could
have actually fitted plenty of room on
the road
I promise me this Rose what let me get
up on that door with you come on darling
there's room for two
I wouldn't be here without you man I
thank you
I would have shared the raft we have
since done a thorough forensic analysis
with a hypothermia expert took two stunt
people that were the exact body mass of
Kate and Leo and we put sensors all over
them and inside and we put them in ice
water and we tested to see whether they
could have survived by this method or
that method or that method the answer
was there was no way they could both
survive so we actually did a scientific
study to put this whole thing to rest
and drive a stake through its heart once
and for